ça arrive parfois que l'on met deux ou
trois femmes en cause de 40 à 50
étudiants
marie-philippe il se sent à sa place en
génie logiciel
elle veut obtenir une maîtrise et à son
propre blog
convaincu qu'il faut accueillir plus de
filles en génie j'ai eu ma première pour
ce soir sera menée en 4e année donc je
trouve que c'est pas mal le tard dans la
mort plus parce que je sais qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui peuvent abandonner en cours
de route donc je pense qu'avoir des
modèles féminins qui nous enseigne ça
peut nous aider à rester dans la bonne
voie x un gala h à l'école de
technologie supérieure le ts compte 16 %
de femmes parmi le personnel enseignant
une bonne raison de continuer de changer
les préjugés et le ts on a 17 % de
filles globalement dans tout mon
programme c'est un pourcentage qu'on
veut bien sûr augmenter c'est un
un point qui nous tient à coeur ça me
tient à coeur personnellement aussi
j'étais moins présent le 6 décembre 1989
à l'école polytechnique le génie
chimique qu'il étudiait à l'époque
intéressait déjà plus de filles que
d'autres disciplines du génie vous direz
il ya une prise de conscience de
l'importance de la diversité dans notre
société qui est globale qui dépasse le
simple cadre des femmes en génie des
équipes plus diversifiée vers une plus
créative entre normands plus le réflexe
d'aller vers des professions de médecine
ou dans le soin de tenter lui voit pas
nécessairement la possibilité en génie a
marqué en appelez moi j'ai des amis qui
travaillent qui ont fait génie mécanique
mais qui travaillent pour des implants
pour les genoux et les hanches on est
vraiment dans les coeurs et 15% des
membres de l'ordre des ingénieurs du
québec sont des femmes aujourd'hui
contre 4,3 en 1989
une campagne menée par ingénieurs canada
est en cours
on espère que 30 % des ingénieurs
finissant en 2030 seront des femmes à
l'école polytechnique
la proportion d'étudiants dans les
années 80 avoisinait les 15 %
ces 28 % aujourd'hui le groupe d
ingénieuse soutiennent et informe les
étudiantes de le ts dernièrement c'était
une conférence sur la négociation
salariale
un sujet sensible puisqu'il y a toujours
un écart salarial entre les femmes et
les hommes ingénieurs qui gagnent en
moyenne 12 % de plus que leurs collègues
féminines i see and with despatie radio
canada montréal